サッブ パパッサーサ アカラナン クサラッサー ウパーサンパダー サチット パリヨー ダパナン エータン ブッダナサーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
光が私の顔に当たっちゃって
皆様の顔が見えなくなっています
ですから 皆様理解できるかできないか
ちょっとチェックできないんです
はい あのね この話を始まる前に言いたいことがございまして
あの 生きている間ではね
仏教では人間輪廻転生すると思っているんだからね
どこに生まれたっても
豊かで必要なものは全部揃って
ない足らないという泣き事がなく
生きられたい 生きたいと思うならば
いろいろお布施してくださいとお釈迦様に説かれているんです
お布施の徳っていうのは
そうやってどこに生まれても豊かで生まれるんで
皆様飼っているワンちゃんたちもね
結構何か悪いことしているになっちゃったんだけど
お布施はしたことがあると思いますね
だからかなり贅沢に住んだからね
はい そのお布施の中でも一番最高な優れたお布施は法施と呼ぶんですね
真理を教えること 真理を教えると
人々の命そのものが助かるんですね
地獄に落ちないで 天界などで回って解脱に達することまでできるんです
だから 法施 法を施すことが一番究極なお布施なんです
それ以上優れたお布施はありません
寄付はありません 真理の寄付
それでちょっと問題がありまして
説法できるのは我々出家だけなんですね
在家の方々は仏教を学んだってもうなかなか難しいと思います
これはかなりの修行と訓練が必要なんです
それで在家の方々は別なことをするんですね
お坊さんたちに説法できるように
いろんなことを用意してあげる
そうすると説法 法施するんじゃなくて
法施させる そうすると
するよりはさせているんだからね
もっと上じゃないかなと
どこか だから説法できない一般の方々はお坊さんたちに法施させるという多大な最高な善行をする
その善行をすると 自分自身には常に気づきがあって生きられます
気づきがあるということは
物事をよくわかっている状態で
で 講演の中でも出てくるテーマがありまして
この認知症になる 物忘れっていうのは問題が人間にあるんですね
それは起きないんです
いつでも心がシャーって働くんです
ですから それならば法施するべきということになっちゃうんですね
それでもお釈迦様やら説法を聞くとかね
あるいは瞑想する 瞑想修行するとかね
そういう場合はすぐたちまち解脱に達する人々は
過去でそういう法施をした人々なんですね
真理を施した方々なんですね
そういうことで 法施というのはすごい大事なんです
なんでこれ関係ないことが言ったのかと
今日のこの会場を用意して
今日の法話をね 行ったのはこの柳淳一さんですね
ですから 今日の会場費とかね
全部お布施をして 法施として施しを行いましたので
我々私は柳淳一さんとその家族
お母様とともに 皆様に仏法僧の御加護がありますように
幸福で安穏で生きられますように
早くも苦しみを乗り越えて解脱に達することができますようにと誓願いたします
賛成する方々も3回サードゥ
サードゥ サードゥと言ってください
サードゥ サードゥ  はい
ではお話に入ります あの
今日のテーマは死に方入門ですよ
よく来たなと思いますね
たくさん方々は  なんか人を殺す行為になっちゃう
変でしょ タイトルは だからもう殺し方入門みたいな
死に方入門って  死に方入門ということでね
人は誰だって死ぬんですから
まあ怖くない 不安にならない
後悔しない死に方をしたいという気持ちで
ですから 今日は苦し方の法話ではないんです
えーと 法話の中でちょっと辛口っぽくて厳しいことを言いますけど
あまり気にしないでください
なんかおだてて喋ると
私はすごくつまらなくなっちゃうんです
自分が眠くなっちゃうんです
だから皆様が眠くなってもいいんだけど
私が眠くなったら大変でしょう
そういうわけで 結構厳しくいろいろ言葉を喋ります
で 皆様がそこはちょっとフィルタリングして
ポイントだけを取っておいてください
はい あの お釈迦様がおっしゃったこの死に方っていうのはあるかどうかよくわかりませんだけど
まず仏教の真理に入ってみます
理性をこれ 何でしたっけ？かぶる強烈
強烈 強烈っていうのはものすごいボルダーということでいうと
とんでもない石なんですね
で 我々の理性を何かとんでもないもので隠してるんですね
潰されてるんですね 現実に背くことで
一切の悩み苦しみが現れる
だから我々にはものすごいあらゆる悩み苦しみがある
すべての生命 皆様に限ったものじゃない
生きるものなら 犬 猫 虫
みんな生きること大変なんです
苦しいんです 悩みがいっぱいあるんです
動物なんか悩みがないと思っちゃうでしょ
あるんですよ 縄張りの問題とか
いろいろあるんですよ
餌があってもボスが食べるまで待たなくちゃいけないしね
大変でしょ ライオンの群れにしても
メスライオンたちが獲物取るんだけど
オスライオンが先に食べる
あいつお腹いっぱい食べるまで待たなくちゃいけない
残るか残らないかもわからない
だから結構悩みがあるんですよ
メスライオンいっぱい食べなきゃおっぱいあげなくちゃあかんしね
まあオスライオンはそんなことは気にもしない
だからどんな生命にしても問題あるんですよ
特に食べられてしまうという恐れが
相当大変ですよ 皆様は天国みたいな感じで
皆様を誰も食べませんよ
あげたっても気持ち悪いと言われるでしょうね
だから我々にとっては食べられる恐怖感がないんですよ
でも動物たちは食べられるという恐怖感を持ってますよ
だから生きることは誰にだって大変なんです
動物には苦しみを乗り越えることは不可能ですが
我々にはなんとかできるんですね
これ 方法というのは 我々が理性を発酵させて
理性っていうのは巨大なダイヤと思ってください
かなりでっかいダイヤです
運ぶことを 難しい 重くて運べないぐらいでっかいダイヤとしましょう
地勢は しかし それはとんでもない
富士山みたいなでっかい強力で抑えられているんです
抑えられていると どんどんそこへひび割れも入ったりする
それで悩み 苦しみが生まれるんです
はい それで現実に背くというポイントなんです
我々は現実を見ない 現実
1 2つあります 冬は寒いとかね
夏は暑いと現実でしょ
で 地球は自転公転するとか現実でしょ
で 春 花が咲く 川が流れるとかね
現実です 現実です 皆さんが背く
異論立てないで そのまま事実真理として認める
私が背くと言ったのに
そのような現実に誰も背かないんです
そうでしょうと 当たり前でしょうと
と思う この理解で助かっています
だから我々は現実を認めることで助かってますよ
冬は寒いと認めるんだからこそ
こんなものを着ているでしょ
私は勝手に冬なんか寒くないよとか偉そうなことを言っちゃうと
自分が死んじゃいますよ
だからこういう現実 現実 1人間みんな認める
その点で助かって幸せでいる
川が流れることを知っているし
まあ雨が降ったらね もうちょっと氾濫する恐れもあると知っているし
それなりに手を加えて幸せでいる
ここまでは理性的ですね
はい 皆さんはもう理性的です
大丈夫ですね よかった
それ現実逃避に行きます
人は老いる 体が徐々に弱くなる
様々な病気にかかる 愛する者は自分から離れていく
嫌な人々 物事と付き合わなくてはならない
生まれたものは必ず死ぬ
これも現実ですね 現実 2 しかし
決して見て見たくはないね
対立したいでしょ だからどう？アホじゃないんですかね
対立するんですよ 老いないようにとかね
病気には絶対なれてやるもんかとかね
現実に背く 現実 2 これとても危険ですよ
現実 1 を認めることで助かっているでしょ
幸せになっているでしょ
なんで現実 2 否定するんですかね
だからあらゆる苦しみを味わうんです
ものすごく馬鹿を見るんですよ
すべての悩み苦しみの原因
それなんです いたって簡単でしょ
仏教は 現実 1 はみんな認める
現実 2 には真っ向から反抗する
だから馬鹿を見る それにむち打つんですよ
ありえないことに挑戦するんですよ
年くる 年取ることは止められないでしょ
なんで若々しくいたいと思っている ？
地球の自転公転を止められません
頑張っても無駄です 私たちはやっていることは
地球の自転公転をやめてみようとストップさせようというような感じなんです
だから年取らないようにしよう
病気にかからないようにしようということは無理です
これ 認めた方が究極の安穏が生まれるんです
だけど 私はすごい年取って楽しいんですよ
若い時やったことは一つも今できなくて
これ楽しいんです 昔はものすごい速足で歩いたんです
他の人々はいくらかジョギングぐらいスピードで一緒に来なきゃ
私は歩けなかったんです
今 私はよっこらせとゆっくりゆっくり歩くんですね
昔は階段というのはだいたい 3つぐらい
ぱっぱっぱっと 今は一つ一つ一つ一つとかね
楽しいんですよ 決して苦しくないんです
だからなんでこれやとか
なんでこの足が弱くなったのかと文句言っちゃうと苦しくなっちゃうんです
阻止する対応を作れませんね
無駄ですね やったらありえない
皆様 どんな科学的なテクノロジー
技術を持ったっても 対応を阻止することできる
何考えてるんですかね
というわけで これぐらいバカやと認めてくださいよ
我々人間は 現実を認めるんだけど
現実には認めない その中で一番大事なのは現実二なんです
なぜならば自分の命ですから
現実には自分自身の生き方だから
なんで生き方に対してちんぷんかんぷんなことをするんですか
天道なんとかって言うんですね
あべこべのことをなんでやってるんですかね
だから誰だって幸せになれない
しかし 死なないことに挑戦する
完璧に健康な状態で生きていきたいと思う
現実味に迫っているが
自分の挑戦は無駄で 極限に無知であることを認めない
皆様に皆様みんな本当にとんでもないアホやと言ったら怒るでしょ
怒りますね 機嫌が悪くなりますよ
でもアホでしょ 本当は
だって現実に迫っているんだからね
現実に迫ることが無知というんです
じゃあ聞きます こちらで死にたくてたまらない人がいる
いないでしょ まあそんなのは普通やと思う
思わないんです 理性の対義語は感情なんですね
理性の敵ですよ 感情っていうのは
対義語っていうのはそういう意味なんですね
アントニン英語で言えばアントニンで調べたら対義語出まったからね
で 感情 だから私的に簡単ですよ
私って理性的な人間ですか？と知りたければ
私に感情ある？あるんだったら理性はないんです
感情って 例えばユーモアを持つことは感情じゃないんですよ
理性なんです どんな問題もちょっと笑ってみるのが理性なんです
問題起きたら あーやだ
これはいややと言ったら感情です
問題起きたらなんだこれって感じで笑っちゃう
笑って対応する と言ったら理性なんです
落ち込んだら感情です
そういうことで 私たちに理性あるか
どの程度にあるかということをチェックできます
例えば やるべきことがあっても
なんか気持ち的にやらないとかね
あれ 気持ち的にやらないっていうのはダメなんですよ
気持ちはどうでもいいんで
やるべきことをやっちゃうと理性なんです
例えば 嫌な人にも慈悲を結ぶ
自分のライバルにも 自分の足を引っ張る人にも
どうか幸せでありますようにと
気持ち的にはできないでしょ
だから理性がないんです
理性があるならば なんのことなく
別にあいつはもう私の敵ですけど
でも幸福でありますようにと
敵だからなんで別に敵だからといって不幸になっていいわけないでしょう
というふうに理性使えるんです
それでよく勉強してください
理性の対義語は感情 死にたくないとは感情であり
気持ちですね みんな持ってますよ
死にたくないというのは理性じゃない
死ぬんだからね だから死にたくないという気持ちは感情であって
理性はないという意味なんです
理性がなかったら苦しまなくちゃあかんです
ハチャメチャ苦しまなくちゃいけないんです
地球を止めようとするような働きなんです
老いたくないとは感情であり
主観的な気持ちです 客観的な理由はありません
例えば 誰だってね 聞いたらあんた年取りたい
年は取りたくないんだけど
なんで？理由はないんです
あんた死にたい？死にたくない
ただ感情だけ 死にたくない
年取りたくないとかね
ですから これ理性の反対なんですね
感情はありえない 現実できない期待
希望 願望を作るんです
感情っていうのはガンみたいなもんですよ
ガンがガンがどんどん成長すると
もう肺臓も攻撃するわ
腎臓も攻撃するわ もう大腸小腸も
小腸にあんまりガンにならないんだけどね
大腸攻撃するわ どんどんむしばんでいくでしょ
ありがたくないね だから感情ある人は
理性が弱い人 いつでもありえない
非現実的な期待 願望 夢
作るわ 作るわ 作るわ これどんどんむしばんで自己破壊していっちゃうんです
全く幸福に生きる生きていられなくなっちゃうんです
生きることに挑戦すればするほど
ますます悩み 苦しむことを結果として得る
だから我々は生きて生きていきたい
生きていきたいばっかり頑張ってますけど
いつだって若々しくいたいとかね
30歳の体力と能力とスタミナで 70歳になってもいたいとかね
頑張ってはいるんですね
頑張ってください そのうちくたびれますよと
何の幸せもなくなりますよと
はい これでワンセクション終わります
次のセクションに入ります
死という現実 これ現実にですよ
現実から逃避する あるいは受け止めて落ち着く
どちらでよろしいですか？地球は公転する
現実でしょ 我々は受け止める
例えば地球は丸いということを知らないでしょ
私は知ります どう見たっても平らに見えますけど
一度も経験したことはないんです
地球が丸いと でも あれ事実だから認める
私は誰とも 俺は見る限り地球は平らだからね
嘘を言うなと喧嘩したことは一度もないんです
でもあったんですよ 地球って丸いというんだけど
これは丸く見たいなという気持ちがあったんですね
でも これ叶ったんです
だってみんなね 飛ぶでしょ
宇宙に行ってビデオでね
もう映してくれるんだからね
この間 日本のね 飛行士もね
行って 有名な人でね ずっと日本テレビで放送したでしょ
自分が撮るハイビジョンの画像をね
ほんのちょっと時間待ってると
昼があって 夜があって
また昼が現れる 面白かったんですよ
だから やっぱりこれ結構丸いなと
...はあるんだけど
私には目では見えませんね
だから現実を認めたら落ち着くんです
私たちは現実から逃避するというとんでもないことをやろうとする
はい これからは突然仏教の話に入ります
死随観という言葉 これパーリ語でマラナヌッスっていうんです
死という現実をそのまま観察することは
釈尊が推薦する瞑想の一つです
だって人間アホだから
死なない年取らないと思ってるんだから
不幸になるでしょ？ひどく苦労するでしょ
だからお釈迦様がこのアホらしさをなくすために
死随観という瞑想をします
さいと 推薦するんです
この瞑想は今日紹介できませんだけど
こういう省略するとこんな感じ
すべての生命は必ず死ぬ
死は避けられない 水に描く禅の禅のように命は消え去る
死は確実 あ 命は儚い 死は確実
そういう瞑想のフレーズをずっと念じるんです
これパーリ語だったらすごい節に乗って言えるんですね
ジービタンアニエタンマラナンニエタンって瞑想のフレーズがあって
それ我々よくやってるんですね
これを歌えるんですよ
ジービタンアニエタンマラナンニエタン
これを歌っているとなんとなくその気持ちになっちゃいますよ
ジービタンアニエタン
命は儚いという意味なんですね
マラナンニエタン 死は確実
で 私たちは必ず朝晩唱えなくちゃいけない
結構ありますよ 私は朝しか唱えてないんだけどね
そういうことを言い聞かせて
心に この無知な心を理性の心に入れ替えるんです
その時 現実に逆らっている反理性的な感情を発見する
そこで命は儚い 死は確実と言っていると
なんとなく気持ち悪いとかね
なんだ 俺ってこんなこと言ったら暗くない？とか思っちゃうんですよ
誰だって死ぬんだぞと言っちゃうという超暗い話だとかね
思っちゃうでしょ 感情です
これ 超暗いじゃなくて超明るいんです
では 皆様と私の方がどちらが明るいんですかね？照明当てている方からじゃなくてね
（笑）私にとっては何度も冗談なんですよ
世の中 でも私は死は確実っていうことは念じて瞑想して
である程度でね ヴィパッサナー瞑想をやっていたんだからね
必要な程度まではやってはいるんです
だからこれ最初に実時間やると
なんかやべえ 怖い 暗いという感じが出てくる
それが自分が感情的であって
理性的でないっていう意味になるんですね
そういう風に感情が出たら破っちゃえばいいんです
地球の自転公転を止めようとしたことをやっていたのだと気づくならば
納得するならば 心は安穏に達する
ちょっとややこしい文章になりましたけど
私たちは死にたくない
死にたくないと思っていたのは
地球の自転公転をストップさせようとしたようなものであると
なんか極限な馬鹿ではなかったと納得する
それで瞑想は完了です
こんなアホなことをやっていいわけじゃないんだと
死は確実やと納得するんです
そうするとすごい楽になりますよ
ものすごい楽になる だって死は確実だから
我々は一時的に滞在しているでしょ
だけでしょ この世の中でちょっと一時的に
だからすごい気楽なんです
例えば皆様方は自分の家にいる
どこかに旅に出て ホテルに 1 2日泊まる
一番リラックス気分がいいのはどちらにいる時？ホテルにいる時はもう何でもやってくれるんだからね
旅館なんかに泊まったらね
ただ贅沢にいるだけで十分でしょ
ベッドだったらベッドちゃんと用意してあるし
旅館だったら布団だったら
旅館の人々は布団敷いてくれるし
目が覚めたら覚めたで布団がそのままで大丈夫でしょうし
そこでちゃんと朝ごはんを用意してあるし
あんな贅沢 それは一時滞在だからなんですね
だから一時滞在っていうのは気分がいいですよ
なんでこの世の中で我々は一時滞在にしてないんですかね
なんで永住やと思ってるんですかね
じゃあ苦労してくださいと
自分の家で住んでる場合は永住でしょ
掃除しなくちゃいけない
洗濯しなくちゃ で ちょっと水道下水道で問題起きたら
またあっちでいろんなところに電話してお願いしなくちゃいけない
大晦日になってくると大掃除をしなくちゃいけない
時々年取ったって掃除できなくて
もういろいろ専門家に頼まなくちゃいけない
それにも 2 3万かかっちゃう 5
万  6万かかっちゃうしね
大変ですよ 永住すると
ホテルに泊まったら何一つ問題ないんですね
そういうわけで すぐ楽しくなります
その人に 死は自然の現象で悩むべき問題ではない
この瞑想する人にとっては
死っていうのは自然なこと
太陽が昇った 太陽が沈んだような感じで
別にびっくりでなくても
びっくりしなくていいんです
だから仏教の四諦観やって理性作った人にとっては
死に方っていうのは全く管轄外です
だから秘密バラします
死に方っていうのは仏教では一切ないんです
あの今日のあの 説法のお布施した柳さんがね
正しい死に方 こんな死に方
嫌だ こんな死に方とか説明してくるくださいと頼まれたことあるんです
私はこんなのはないんだから
どうしますか？と 仏教の言葉で言うと違うんですよ
認めなさい 現実をと すごい楽になりますよと
死は問題じゃないんだと
皆様 朝起きたらお腹が空いてるでしょ
すごい問題 一度もそれを問題にしたことがある？ないんです
なんか食べちゃう 家で食べるものなんかなくても大丈夫でしょ
会社に行く途中でコンビニでおにぎり 1個買って食べながら行きますからね
全然問題にしないでしょ
ああ困った 悩んだとかね
ああ 落ち込んだ 朝がお腹がすいちゃって
どうしよう 誰も落ち込まないね
かえって楽しいよ 美味しく食っちゃおうと
だから現実を認めた方が楽で楽で仕方がないぐらい楽になるんです
そういうことで 死は現実だと見た人にとっては
生きることが楽で楽でたまらんです
死に方なんかは考える必要もないんです
はい 次のセクションに入ります
これで講演が終わりますよ
終わった 皆様の問いを観察しましょう
でも皆様方はね 本当アホだからね
いろんな希望を持っているんです
それに答えてみます この答えがちょっと辛口になります
現実離れの希望期待の恐ろしい結果に気づく
この現実離れの希望期待っていうのは恐ろしいんですよ
私は前はね 今私は凶暴な獣とみんな思ってるんだから
もうすごい楽ですけど
昔はもういろんな議論するんですね
あなたは希望は良くないと言ったって
人間が希望あるから明るく生きてるんではないか
あなたの話は認めませんとかね
それは話答えたって意味がないんだけど
私はじゃあ凶暴な獣になってやるぞと獣の態度を取っちゃった
それからあまり反論は出てこないんです
で 本当に余計な希望あると暗いんですよ
はい 問い1 死ぬのは怖い
だから私の答え あのね
あんた経験したことがある？ないでしょ
経験もしていないのに
あれは怖いというのは馬鹿じゃないんですかね
例えばこの食べ物まずい
あんた食べたことある？いや
生まれてからこの方は食べたことはないんだと
だったらアホでしょ だから死ぬのは怖いっていうのは
何の理論も成り立たない感情なんです
理性作っちゃえば 理性ある人は
それはその時 それだけ
現実見るだけ あ 息が苦しくなっちゃった
まあ心臓が痛くなっちゃったとかね
そのまま体が機能低下すると心だけ働きます
その時痛くないんです
死ぬ前はすごいきついんですよ
肉体に心がついてる間は
だってお腹が痛い 胸が痛い
呼吸できなくて苦しい
管いっぱい入れちゃってね
もうものすごい嫌な気分があるんで
その時生きていきたい気持ちがあるんです
それで肉体には生きられなくなる
活動できなくなっちゃうと心が体から離れるんです
でも肉体はまだ呼吸していますけどね
心から心が肉体から離れるんだから痛くないんです
心が離れちゃうとすぐ心臓停止しちゃうんです
死ぬ瞬間 人々を観察してできればね
死ぬまでは大変ですよ
苦しい もう水を飲みたいと言うんだけど
飲めないわ いるはいる
でも突然体が急激に痛くなって
瞬間ですごく落ち着いて突き進みます
それは客観的に観察するとそういうことなんだから
死ぬのが怖いと思ったら
大馬鹿者やと思うしかないんですね
これは妄想の結果 我々は死を観察するんじゃなくて
瞑想するんじゃなくて妄想するんですよ
そうすると怖いという感情が出てくる
現実に背いて背を向いている感情に負けている
現実を見たくはないという感情が勝っているんですね
だから死ぬのは怖いという気持ちが生まれる
死にたくない 死にたくないというのが問いなんですね
死にたくないと思う人々は無理です
答えは簡単です 私は死にたくない
あのね 無理ですと それで言いますけど
私はスリランカに昔 日本に来る前にかな
日本に来ていたかな 当時で
昔泊まっていたお寺のすごいお年寄りのお坊さんがいてね
住職のね 突然病気になっちゃったんですね
このお坊さんが まあいろんなことを言うわ
言うわ うるさくてしょうがない
鍵は誰？あのあなたか
もう私は今までこのお寺は大事に発展してきまった
あれやこれやとかね 私はうるさくてももうこれから病院に運ぶんだからね
あのね あんたお寺持って死ぬつもりですかね
いきなり聞いたんです
年下の坊主にそんなすごい乱暴なこと言われたことは
ガクンと黙ったんです
あんたと言わない先生だからね
でああ ジョロは死ぬときはお寺を持っていく？と聞いたんです
それだけ 私の顔をこうやって睨んで黙ったんです
そのままタクシーが来たんだから
病院に連れて行ったんです
だから死ぬのは怖いと言ったら
はっきり無理や そんなこと言うべきなんですけどね
皆様はそれなりにちょっと優しく喋ってください
簡単なことは無理 アホ思います
とそこを頭に入れて 適当に方便で喋ってください
はい 問い２ 明るく死にたい
このフレーズは皆様が読んだでしょう
パティパダーニアのこの今日の講演の内容をね
書いてあったんですね
宣伝フレーズ そこから全部パクっちゃったんです
明るく死にたい 体の機能が低下低下することで苦しみを感じるのは普通です
だから死ぬということは
この肉体は活動できない状態なんですね
この馬鹿が明るくなりたいと思っているんです
死とはこれ以上動かないという最低の状態なんですよ
例えば 足の関節が風呂待ちで硬くなったら足が機能しないでしょう
あれって楽しい？楽しくないんで苦しいんです
この苦しみの頂点は死ぬ時なんです
なのにこのアホが明るく死にたいと思っているんです
明るく死ぬんじゃなくて
肉体が与えてくるくる苦しみに堪える精神力が必要なんです
だから何やという状態
苦しいよ だから何ですかと
息がものすごい大変です
別にという 苦しいな 当然ながら
みんなこの明るく死にたいと思う場合は
体の調子が良くてニコニコ状態なんですけど
これはもうちょっと理性で考えなくちゃいけないんですね
心臓発作の時 なんで楽しいでしょう？と思える
だって人が心臓発作でも亡くなるでしょ
心臓発作 あー気分がいい
楽しいと思える？思ったら相当アホでしょ
あれってすごい苦しいんですよ
心臓発作起こしちゃうと誰だって漏らしちゃいますから
しかし 死の瞑想をしていたならば
ああ なるほど これでなるほど死ぬんだ
こんなすごい肉体の苦しみがあって亡くなるんだ
それで落ち着くんです
心臓発作の苦しみが消えるわけじゃないんです
感情的な妄想期待をやめればいかがでしょうか
私の答えは この感情的な気持ちを捨てましょうと
明るく死にたいとか 余計なことを思うなよと
放っておけ そんなのは
苦します人も苦しんでやっと死ぬ人もいます
これ 世の中の死に方はいろいろ様々なんです
なんか突然パッと死ぬ人もいる
まあ 3ヶ月間も頑張って
やっと死んだと 時々 1 年間も
もうちょっとわからない
明日かも 明後日かもとかね
という植物のような状態で苦しんでいる人もいますよ
それはどうすることもできない
管理できない はい これで思い出したケースがあるんです
私のスリランカのお寺の
日本に私のお寺がないんですからね
隣の家があります 最近の
その家の人が一緒に私の車を運転してくれるんですけど
その人のおじちゃんが
おじいさんが おじさんが住んでいたんですね
田舎から連れてきて この人を面倒見てあげたんです
おじさんが結婚してなかったし
すごい痩せた人で すごい元気でしたけどね
すごい痩せ方で ものすごく仕事するんですね
怠けません だから必要なものを全部あげてるのに仕事をしなくていいんですよ
でも仕事する もう 最後はほとんど大人の仕事をしていたんですね
結構労働でしょ 結構労働
もう朝からものすごい
そればっかりやっているんですね
ものすごい どう見ても労働者で見えるような
その人がこの最近 体も洗って
髭を剃って どこかで座っちゃったんですね
座ってそのままガクッと
私より少し年下なんです
それで子供たちやらみんなおじいちゃん
おじいちゃんって動かない
それで大人に行ったら亡くなっているんです
もう体もちゃんと洗って
髭まで剃って座ってガッと終わる
それで私に連絡 連絡あったんですよ
で だからずっとその人
おじさんとはではなくて
あの運転する子とはすごい仲がいいんだからね
連絡あって それで私はなんか一般的にはね
あの悔やみの言葉言うでしょ
私の言葉なんですかと思う
よかったね あいつは幸福でよかったと
そうすると向こうもそうだと思いますよと
ほんの瞬間に亡くなって
葬式はものすごい なんか見事にうまくいったと
みんな人々が来て だってパッと死んだんだだからみんなすごくすごいことやと思っちゃうんですね
そういう人もいるんですよ
世の中で なぜかで その人はずっとお寺のお仕事をして
仕事をして 重労働で お寺に仕事なかったらどこかに行って仕事をして
1日明るく生きているんです
とにかく だからその徳が効いたでしょうね
そこでとにかく突然死んだんだから
病院に連れて行って ちょっと解剖して
あれ取る あの死のなんて言いますか
サーティフィケートね
証明書を取らなきゃいけない
埋葬できませんだからね
だからこのなんか心臓の血管破裂してるんだっていう話で
もう本当かどうか分かりませんだけどね
だから私はおかしくない？あんな痩せてる人の血管がね
あれほど仕事をする労働者のね
血管が強いのは決まってますけどね
まあとにかくぽっくり死んじゃったんですね
だからこんな幸せないんですよ
だからって それが私もっていうことはね
こんなのは余計な妄想をやめましょう
もう一人ケースあります
それは私は確かめたケースではないんだけど
この講演は昨日作りながら
夜ネットのネットで説法を聞いてるんです
いろいろ説法を聞いてながら
もういい加減でこれをアップロードしてるんです
もう 集中は説法に行ってる
で やってる で ちょっと何かニュースがあって
この  7歳の子供が私は天国に行きますと言って亡くなったと
なんか変なことやるんだなと思って見ないと思っていたんだけど
やっぱり気になってそのセクションチェックしてみたんですね
で 写真があって すごい可愛い可愛い子なんだよ
男の子で ニュース読んでみたら
あのニュースを先にも知っていたんですけどね
その子は小学校のみんなに
私は結婚式に行きますからね
また帰ってきませんよと
教室の中の友達にみんなに言って
先生たちにも言って 金曜日ですよ
結婚式に結婚式というんですかね
そういう ところに行きますからね
帰ってきませんからと
そこで学校出ようと思ったら
あ 何々ちゃんに言うの忘れちゃったとかね
また戻ってきて みんなに結婚式やりますからね
親戚のね だからそれに行きますよと
でも帰りません これからはと
で 報告するんです みんなまあ子供の話だから
あまり気にしなかったんですよ
そこで土曜日か日曜日かね
スリランカでは普通の人々は三輪車で行くんですね
タイとかインド スリランカでよくあります
タクシーでね そちらに家族を乗って結婚式に行って
帰るときは事故を起こしちゃって
両親は怪我しましたけど
この子供は重傷で  2 日間意識不明の状態でそのまま息を引き取ったみたい
だからみんな悲しくて
ちっちゃな子供が死んじゃったんだからと言ってね
それからあの子供の部屋
片付けてみると 子供の字でいろんな字で書いているみたいで
私はこの世は地獄みたいだと
だからみんな悪いことをしないでいい人間になれと
私は天国に帰りますと
と書いてあって これを隠しておいてあったみたい
だからこの子はちっちゃな子はもう先に知ってるんですね
自分が死ぬんだと で それまたこれから天国に行きますからっていう感じでね
この世の中はね 人間の世界は地獄やと
悪い人々がいっぱいいて
だから自分の友達にメッセージはいい人間になってくださいと
優しい人間になってくださいという
7歳ですよ だから世の中でそういういろんな人はいる
それでがんになって もう末期状態になっても死にたくはない
先生なんとかしてくださいっていう
もう不幸な人々もいる
そういうことで これも関係ないね
明るく死にたいとかね
それよりは答えは風邪引いたら気持ち悪いでしょ？お腹が痛くなったら気持ち悪いでしょ
体が何かにぶつけたら痛くてたまらんでしょ？だから何考えてるんですかね
肉体の機能低下すると最悪状態なんですよ
だから覚えておきましょう
そんなのは逃げられません
それで私たちの目の前で死にかけている人々がいたら
極端に心配してください
この人は大変だから 体が痛くて呼吸できなくて
特にこの死ぬ前にこの腸は停止するんですよ
ちょうど胃袋はスーッとグニャグニャやってますからね
これってものすごい痛いんですよ
人は様々ですけど で 健康でもうポツンと死ぬ人々の場合は
例えば体が健康で 心臓も大丈夫
すべて大丈夫 血圧も何もない人々の場合は
寿命が終わって死ぬ場合は寿命が終わったという信号は
腸が止まる 腸が止まると食べられないんです
まあいいやと言って横になる
大体 1 日で死にます そういうわけで
肉体は機能低下することだから
今も肉体機能低下嫌でしょ？例えば肩こりって楽しい？肩こりっていうのはここら辺硬くなっちゃって機能しないでしょ
嫌じゃない？痛くて だからそれって現実なんです
逃避するんじゃないんです
肉体のことだから 自己管理不可能だから
どうでもいいのではないかと
私の答え この苦しいのは肉体ですよ
自己管理できない だからどうでもいい
死ぬ時の苦しみは そんなのはどうでもいいんです
どうすることもできない
しかし 自分以外の人が亡くなる時は極端に心配してあげてください
その人はもう耐えられない苦しみを味わっています
間もない 間もなく死ぬ
です だから頑張ってくださいって一言葉言わないでください
何に頑張るんですかね
ああ 苦しいでしょうね
まあしょうがないねとかね
そういう言葉かけてください
ちょっと動いたらもう動いたんだけど
ちょっと今の状態では動けないねとかね
同感してあげた方がいいんです
そんなこと言わないで
頑張って 私はそろそろ死ぬかも
いや おじいちゃん何言ってるんですか？と
日本人はそう言っちゃうんです
言って相手を人口に落としちゃうんです
私はもうそろそろ死ぬでしょう
そういうことでしょうね
誰だって死ぬんだからね
って言ってください 別に失礼じゃないんです
別に おじいさん 誰だって死ぬんだからね
おじいさん 心は明るい
楽しくいる 肉体は苦しいんだけどね
とかね そういう風にあるままのことを喋れば
本人が死後天国に行くんです
問三 ちょっと早く飛ばさなくちゃいけないんですね
悔いなく死に死にたい
悔いなく 私の答え 悔いなく悔いと読むんです
これは うん 悔いなく生きてみてください
こいつは朝から晩まで悔いばっかしで生きていて
死ぬ時だけ悔いなく生きる
何考えてるんですかね
だから今から皆様も何があっても悔いなく明るく生きてみてくださいと
成功します 次のみんなの問いは迷惑かけたくないと
子供に人に迷惑かけたくない
迷惑かけないで死にたいとかね
調子に乗ること 調子に乗ってるんで
自己主張ですよ これはわがままです
人に迷惑をかけ なんか人に迷惑をかけないで死にたいなと思って
なんとなく優しい人だなとわかるで感じるでしょ
おかしい それはおかしい
なぜならば 生きること自体が他人に自然に迷惑をかけることですよ
何考えてるんですかね
今日昼ご飯食べた弁当の肉
魚なかった だから他の生命は死んでるでしょ
米を作るために田んぼを耕しちゃうと
あれもある程度自然破壊でしょ
自然っていうのは 植物は好き勝手に成長する世界でしょ
我々はそうさせません
雑草を取り除いて稲だけを
だから この服などなど工場で作ってるでしょ
自然破壊じゃない 男性の方々はみんな結婚していると思いますけどね
すごい調子に乗りやがって
毎日奥さん作ってるご飯食ってるで
皿も洗ってあげないでしょ
奥さんに迷惑じゃない？日曜日くらいでも男の腕を振るって料理作ったらどうですかね
やらない ゴーナしている
こんな生き方をして迷惑かけたくない
いい加減にしろ 朝から晩までハチャメチャ迷惑に生きていて
だから仏教的な態度では生きること自体迷惑なんですよ
他人に 自然環境に 自分自身にも
だからお釈迦様は解脱に達した
達しなさいと言ってるんです
そういうわけで 迷惑をかけたくないという
あの あの 頼まれた質問ですよ
これ説明してくださいと
説明しました いい加減にしろよと
困っている人を助けて
人は幸せを感じます これ大事なポイント
私たちはみんなに迷惑をかけているかも
でも私が困っている人を助けると
私が幸せ感じるんです
いいことできてよかったと
例えば車椅子の人が階段
車椅子のあれスロープありますね
自分で苦労して上を上行く
後ろからちょっと押してあげる
何のことなく その人は苦労してあれ
車輪回さなくていいでしょ
その人はあ よかったという気持ちになるでしょ
その人はそう気持ちになるとなろうとなろうなんか関係なくて
自分が人を助けちゃったという幸せ感じるでしょ
他人の幸せに善行為に邪魔をしないでください
意味がわかる 自分が年取って倒れちゃって
人の助けが必要になる
そうすると助けてくれる人々は
自分を運んでベッドに入れる人は善行為しているんです
人を助けているんです
だから俺なんか人に迷惑をかけないで死にたくないと思うのはすごい態度でかいですよ
周りの人々は誰でもいいんですよ
自分を助けたら その相手が幸福
幸せ感じるんです だから感謝の気持ちぐらい持ったらどうですか
ありがとうねとか 本当に助かりました
あなたって本当に仏様みたいな人ですね
一言言って 迷惑をかけたくないじゃなくて
ほぼ寝たきり状態でね
家族が自分をお風呂に入れてあげる
あーいやだ この人生は子供たちに迷惑をかけて
なんてこと 私は早く死にたいと地獄に落ちますよ
ガバすりすりしちゃって
ではなくて みんな大変ですから
年寄りをお風呂に入れるのは
本当に君たちって大変ですね
仏様みたいですねとかね
苦労して仕事もいろいろあれやこれやとやって
君たちに助けられて 私って本当に幸せ
ありがたい ありがたい
ありがたいと言ってみてよ
それって人間 素晴らしい人間なんです
それがやりたくない 感謝したくない
他人に頼りたくないということはおかしい
私だって一人で生活していますけど
でも皆様に助けられているんですよ
たとえこの講演 皆様聞くでしょうに
そこでよくの死に方を勉強するために来たんだからね
それは置いておいて 皆様方は来るということで
私が大変だ 責任があるといって講演作ったり
いろいろ仏教のことを考えたりして
それで私が生きてるでしょうに
仕事が現れたり だからいつだって皆様に助けられて生きているんです
感謝ぐらい言っちゃったらどうですかね
それで私は私にできる範囲で
人を助ける 人々も私を助けてくれるということは
命の法則で それは乗り越えられません
だから 迷惑かけないで死にたいっていう考えを捨てるしかないんです
問4 たくさんあります
死後の世界も不安だ 輪廻があるのでしょうか
地獄は嫌だ 虫になるのも嫌だというね
よく考える そんなことはね
輪廻 死後の世界は超越した
智慧で発見する事実です
輪廻ありますよ でも私はわかりません
だって超越した智慧がないでしょ？だから正直になってください
ブッダが説く ブッダは決して嘘を言わない
ミッチーも冗談じゃない
だからまあ事実で事実でしょうと
あんた知って 俺は知りませんと
その素直になってほしい
知りません 知りませんだけど
信じる なぜ？ブッダが言ったんだから
ブッダが説かれたことは一つも
間違いは今までなかったんだよと
どう頑張って だから決していい加減なことを説かないでしょうと
だから素直に信じますと
素直に信じることと 輪廻があるそうと胸張ること違いますよ
だから私は輪廻があると信じて生きています
の方が賢くてよろしいんです
信じて生きています あるいは信頼して生きています
ないとでしゃばったことは言いません
あるとも余計なことを言いません
輪廻があるあると言っちゃうと
みんなね じゃあ証明してくださいと言われるんだからね
やられます あなたにはわからないことです
だから善行為をして 悔いのない生き方をする
慈しみで生きる それだけ
だから輪廻あるとかね
そんなのは放っておけ
善行為しなさいと とにかく慈しみで生きてください
慈しみで生きる人は虫にはなりません
これは悪行為する人々
我が強い人 真理に背く人が畜生に生まれます
それは自己自業自得で仕方がないのです
人間なのに獣のように生きているんだから
しょうがない でも我々は善行為するならば
獣は善行為しないでしょ
だから死後 いいところに生まれますよ
良い 良い行為に良い結果とは知っている事実です
我々は良いことをしたら良い結果があると知ってるでしょ
それで十分です 善行為してください
良い結果があります 信じないんだったら
毎日の経験で見てください
良い行為に良い結果があります
法則です だから死後 輪廻怖いとかね
まあ輪廻怖いっていうのは正しいんだけど
地獄に落ちるの嫌だとかね
だったら善行為しなさい
虫になるの嫌だったら善行為しなさい
人間らしく らしく生きてみなさい
それで答えです 善に満たされた生き方をしましょう
朝から晩まで良い言葉を喋って
良いことを考えて 良い行為をして
自分も周りもにも対して慈しみを抱いて
優しい菩薩様のような生き方をすればどう？ 仏様って本当に気持ち悪いんですよ
観音様におねだりするんです
あれくれこれくれと 小池じゃないんですから
自分が観音様のようにいればどうですかね
みんなを助けてあげる
みんなに優しい振る舞いをする
優しい思考をする 優しい言葉を喋る
優しい行為をする 私はこの公園なんかでボランティアでね
おじいさん おばあさんたちがね
ものすごく賑やかで ニコニコきれいに掃除しているんですよ
みんなかっこつけて いろいろいろんなそれなりの服を着て
私は素晴らしい 素晴らしい
この人々と思うんですよ
この人々を見ると 天国は見えねえやと
私は参加しませんだけどね
で まあ行ったり来たりする時のことだからね
うろうろ歩くことはしません
それだったら私も参加しますよ
そういうふうに良いことを考える
良いことを喋る 良い行いをする
それでこの問題は解決する
5番目 人生の後半になってくると
誰しも自分の死について考えて不安になります
早く死を観察した方が良いことですか？答え
人生の後半になってくると
後半じゃないんですよ
後半の後半の後半ですよ
みんな死を考えるのは
4分の3過ぎているのにまだ考えていない
16分の1しか残っていない時は嫌々で死を考える
遅い 今からの死を考えた方がいいんです
小学生の時も人は死ぬんだと考えた方がいいんです
私は前にネットからニュース取って言った場合も
小学生の子供ですよ 死を考えたことではなくて
自分がもう3日後で死ぬということまで知っているので
死んで天国に行くことまで知っているんです
だから生まれた間もないだから過去世を覚えていたでしょうね
あの子はもしかすると天界からね
人間に戻ったら何かいいことをできると思って人間になったでしょうね
人間になってみたら勘違いで
人間ほど気持ち悪い連中がいないんだとわかって
嫌だ この世界はと思って帰りたがって帰っちゃったんです
だから我々の立場から見れば
あんな可愛い子がね 頭もいい子がね
よく勉強して 大学卒業して
結婚して 仕事をして 年取って死んだ方がいいと幸せ
あれって幸せですかね
だから生きている我々は大変だと知っているんだから
なんで子供に苦労させなくちゃあかんですかね
だからそんなのはどうでもいい話で
だからこの我々は自分が死ぬということは
後半になるまで待たないでください
本当は 16分の1で思い出すんです
私ぐらいの年齢になったら
16分の1も残ってないと思いますけど
私の場合は 不安は現実離れで
死に死は不安と思ったら
これは現実離れですよ
なんで現実離れかというと
自分の妄想で死にたくない
でも死ぬ こんな調子だったら死ぬでしょう
それで不安になるんだ
だから死にたくないっていうことは
死を求めることで消える
そうすると不安も消える
不安とは定義している
期待する結果来るだろうという不安なんです
期待 する結果ではないかも
例えば 受験した子供たちが受験結果に発表する日はすごい不安なんですね
ものすごい不安 なんで？結果どうなってるかわからないからなんです
結果はっきりしているならば
不安にならなくていい
受験の場合は結果わからない
でも年取って老いたら死ぬことは確かでしょうに
なんで不安になる？頭おかしい
死にたくないという気持ちまだある
ですから 不安になることはちょっと現実離れ
だから充実した生き方をしましょう
充実した生き方すると
生きていてよかったし
まあそれで十分ということになるんです
これから役に立たねえ
私は  死ぬしかないということになるんです
インド文化的にもそういう気持ちがあるんですよ
生きてるならば 人の役に立つ
人の役に立てない 体がもう弱くなったら早く死ぬ
私も尊敬していた 子供の頃ね
インドの有名な教授がいたんです
かなり有名で もうすごい立派な先生
名前ダンマナーンダ・コオサンビというんですけどね
で あの先生がブッダっていう本を書いちゃってね
ものすごい勉強になりました
研究論文でしたけど その先生が自分の人生観があって
ブッダの研究して本を書いたんだけど
なんかジャイナ教か仏教かはっきりしない先生なんですね
だから 自分が人の役に立たないときは死にますと宣言するんですね
だから体が弱くなったところで断食始めたんです
断食始めたら生徒たちが来て
何するんだ先生 もう死んだら困る
我々はまだまだ勉強することいっぱいあるんじゃないかと言って
ごちゃごちゃ言ったところでまた食べ始めたんです
これ  2回やったんです 2
回っていうのは また何年経ってからやっぱり体が弱いと研究もろくにできない
じゃあ死にますと それで 2回も失敗しちゃって
弟子たちの要求で諦めて
3回目は断食やめなかったんです
お前ら何言ったっても
私はこれ以上人の役に立ちません
だから食いませんと でもそれでもすごく体力あったと思いますよ
そこで死体の写真を見たんです
骨だけほとんど 断食したんだから
死ぬまで あんなのは立派な死に方でしょ
それは立派な死に方 あの先生はまあインド仏教文化だから
生きるならば迷惑だけかけるんじゃなくて
役に立つこともする 恩返しもする
恩返しできなかったら純粋に迷惑だけでしょ
でも偉大なる先生だから
我々はインド文化の人間がインド人じゃないんです
だからインド文化というんです
インド文化の人間は先生とは神様やと思っているんです
尊敬します 拝みます 先生のことなら何でもやる
子供にはやらせません
先生の看病は弟子たちやるんです
それぐらい尊敬します
しかし このコサンビ先生は役に立たんだから
俺はもう だから死にますということで
断食なんて言ったんです
だから私は皆様に言うアドバイスは
充実した生き方してください
どう死んだってもいいんです
すべて捨て去る すべてを捨て去るというフレーズを飲んじ念じる
体感する このフレーズを瞑想です
これも瞑想のフレーズです
すべてを捨て去る これも死を瞑想する方法なんです
すべてを捨て去る すべてを捨て去ると念じてると
まあ執着が少なくなっちゃって解脱に達するんです
パーリ語ではサッバンパハーヤ・ガンタッバンなんです
サッバンパハーヤ・ガンタッバン
日夜念じるべきであると
お釈迦様は直々と書いています
何も持っていけない すべて捨て去る
そうするとどんどん心が軽くなって
これではこれ解脱に達することできる
瞑想フレーズなんです
疲れたならば言ってください
休憩します という六 これ皆様の方でたくさん質問があるんだからね
私に文句言わない方がいいと思います
正しい死に方 大人追って本当すべき死に方を教えて
無理です だって死は自然でしょ
正しいも間違ってもないんですよ
字の場合は正しい書き方と正しくない書き方あります
なぜならば 文字っていうのは自然じゃないんだからね
花を生ける場合は正しい生け方といい加減な生け方はあります
だってあれ不自然だから
でも花そのものに正しい咲き方ある？ないでしょ
だから花が咲くように人は死ぬ
放っておけ そんなの 正しい死に方っていうのはないんです
死は正しいんです そのまま花が咲いたら
それは正しいんです まあそろそろ桜の木も目覚めているでしょ
今日も暖かいんだからね
ちょっと勘違いするでしょうね
さっさと目覚めてしまったら
次また寒くなるんだからね
で まあそれは心配しても意味がないんですね
まあとにかく それって正しいでしょ
サンガツリもついてるのに
桜がまだ寝ていると思ったら
これはおかしい だから
時期に花が咲く 時期に花が散る
時期に葉っぱが出る 時期に葉っぱが落ちる
すべて正しいんです 人は死ぬ
それも正しいんです 地球の正しい自転の仕方を聞いているでしょうかね
なんか私はいつでも地球の例を出すのは
これは無理っていうことを言いたいんです
正しい花の咲き方といったら
人間が反論するんですよ
ちゃんと栄養をあげて
ちゃんと剪定をして ちゃんと温度を管理すれば
もっと見事に花が咲くんじゃないかなと言うでしょ
だから私はその例を取らないんです
皆さん脳細胞知ってるんだから
地球の自転取るんです
じゃあ管理してみてくださいと
だから地球の正しい自転の仕方が聞いているんです
正しい死に方を教えてと
何を聞いてるんですかね
地球の自転は正しいでしょ
心配しないでください
地球は正しく自転しています
正しい生き方を勉強しましょう
逆 正しい死に方ではなく
うん 妄想感情の奴隷となってロボットのように生きるのではなく
理性で感情の感情を意図的に抑えて生きてみる
あなたには正しい死に方は選びません
死に死そのものが正しいんだからね
正しいものに手を入れちゃうと間違っちゃいます
2 たす 2 は 4 答え正しいでしょ 4
ちょっと手を入れてみてください
正しくなくなっちゃうんでしょ
4 にもう一つ足してあげようとかね
じゃあ 5 にしようとかね
4 は形が悪いんだからね 6
ってかっこよく書けますからとかね
いい加減にしろよと だから正しいものに手を加えたら間違います
だからそのまま放っておいて死んでください
余計なことをしないで
しかし 正しい生き方 あなた決めるんです
正しい生き方さえできない人は
残り言いません もう想像してください
死に方は自分の管轄外です
どうすることもできない
生きることは管理できます
悪の生き方も善の生き方も選択できます
生き方さえも管理できない人は人
その努力もしない人が何を考えているんですかね
例えがあります マラソンを走らないで
ゴールのリボンに誇らしげに胸を当ててね
勝ったぞと言いたいんですね
もうその人にどう言えばいい？だからその思想を考えると
そんな人間なんです マラソン走ったならば
まあ遅れたってもいいでしょ
マラソン完走したんだから
かっこいいでしょ マラソン走れないでゴールのところにリボンを貼ってますからね
そちらでやー万々歳と胸を当たってみる
殴られますよ 周りに お前邪魔やと
だから正しい生き方を選択できるのに
それやってください 正しい死に方っていうのは存在しない
死は正しい 常に ボケた両親の介護で長らく苦労して
昨年見送りました 最近私もとみに私もよく間違いですね
打ち間違いと思います
物忘れがひどくなってきました
とみにっていうのは 私も随分という
なるほど 自分もボケて死ぬのではないかと不安です
親の介護のところまで説明します
親の介護をできたことは幸せです
だから親の介護できて
看取ることができてよかった
自分の義務を果たしになった
ボケたくないセクションはね
後半ですね 問題はボケたくない
風邪を引きたくはない
歯抜け になりたくはないなどなどは何でしょうかね
何考えてるんですかね
気持ちはやるかもしれませんけどね
管轄外でしょ 私だって風邪引きたくないんですよ
でも引くときは引きますよ
だから余計なことです
余計に悩むんですね だからボケたくない
ボケたくないというふうにも
風邪引きたくない 引きたくないと思うことと同じで
だからとわからないんだと
引くかも 風邪が ボケたくない
ボケたくないと思ってもボケるから
自分が自然に指令しているんです
アホですよ 大自然に命令している
汝はとかね 例えば風邪っていうのは風邪のウイルスでしょ
汝は私の体に入るなかれと
できることですかね でも聞いてくれる
大自然は 大自然指令しませんよ You
can not command the nature you live according to the nature
as the nature commands
自然は我々に指令するんです
それに従って生きるんです
これあべこべでしょ 雨よ降るなかれと
例えば北海道にとか 青森に住んでいる人は
明日私は出かける用事があるんだから雪降るなよと
頭おかしいでしょ ネイチャーコマンドスアス
ウィーキャノンのコマンドネイチャー
自然は我々に指令する
我々は自然に指令することは不可能
あり得ない だからボケたくないというセクションに私の答えはそれなんです
親の介護をしていろいろ感じたことあるな
あるんだよと 親もやっぱり最後は悲しかったと
惨めだったと そこまで OK です
後半はダメです あなたは全知全能の神ではないと思いますね
だから自然に逆らわないでください
ボケることも自然現象です
それからそこで言わないで
ボケについてちょっと喋りたかったんだけど
やめようと思ったの 私は最初に私自身ボケていたんだからね
だから人にゴチャゴチャ言うところじゃないんです
自分が書いた文章 理性の大愚痴
大義豪とね 辞書を調べて書いたのに
読んで自分がボケちゃって別の変にやとボケちゃったんだからね
だからそんなのは自然なんです
私にとってはただの冗談で
ああ ボケちゃってまずいなと思ってことないんです
日常のすべてを覚える必要ありませんよ
生まれた時から死ぬまでやっていることは
いちいちいちいち覚える必要ある？ないでしょう
覚えて良いものも 忘れた方が良いものもあるでしょうに
我々の問題は 忘れた方が良いものはいくら認知症になって覚えておく
覚えておくべきものはさっさと忘れる
私の問題じゃないんです
これを直して直しましょうよ
物忘れは別にどうったことない
慈悲喜捨 無常 苦 無我などの事実
真理を学んで観察して理解し
納得するならば 世の中のどうでもいいものは忘れてしまっても
心は無常に苦に慈悲喜捨に定着します
だから ボケは決して問題にならない
ボケたんだけど あまりにも仏様になるんです
あまりにも優しくなるだけ
だから認知症とかね まあボケ
ことをとか 物を忘れることとかは
まあ自然現象であるかも
でも 物忘れがあってもいい人や優しい人やとか
なんかお釈迦様になったみたい
観音 観音様になったみたいという風に言われる人間になりましょう
なる秘訣は慈悲喜捨を実践する
講演の初めにやった瞑想
それからブッダが説かれた無常
苦 無我という真理を学ぶ
理解する 納得するとそれは離れません
事実ですから 面白いんですよ
例えば認知症の人に聞いてみて
いるならば 自分の名前を忘れているかも
お母さん お父さんが お父さん
地球は丸いと思う 平だと思う？と聞いてみて
正しく答えるんです 面白くない？認知症が激しい人は
じゃあ 2 たす 3 は？と言ったらわからないかも
2 たす 3 ってわからない
それで認知症と認定する
2 たす 3 はいらんでしょ
生きるために いらんでいい
そんなのは だいたいこの体の体調によって物忘れが起こるかも
これはヴィパッサナー瞑想をすると結構治りますけどね
でもみんな脳の運動やりたくないでしょ
だから文句言わないでください
私はしっかりヴィパッサナー瞑想をしっかりやってくださいと頼んでいるのに
サボるわ サボるわ サボるわ
それででもボケたくはないんだと
知ったことじゃないんで
薬を飲まないんだから
まあそこは冗談で言いましたけど
だいたい気づきの実践で脳が活性化して
記憶力 能力はあるんです
起こるんです では 忘れるものは忘れましょう
それは問題じゃないんです
物忘れは病気じゃないんです
必要なものを覚えて 不必要なものは忘れましょう
で 解決方法は この慈悲喜捨の実践なんです
それから 空・無常・無我の理解なんですね
ん？そこで死ぬ 最後にボケちゃった
認知症になったんだけど
心には無我 あるいは苦
生きることは苦いやと
生きることって大変だよ
苦しいんだ それだけ覚えていれば
その人はもう幸福に死にますよ
だって智慧を持って死ぬんだから
天界にもものすごい上の方に行くんです
息子の顔を忘れているかも
そんな一時的なことで
この世で息子だからね
過去世で息子ではなかったし
来世でも息子じゃなかったし
ただたまたまここで出会っただけでしょ
だからあいつの顔 名前を忘れたってもいいんです
しかし 生きることは苦ですねとか
それを覚えておけば それだけで十分です
死後 天界でもすごい高次元のところに生まれるんです
だから 慈悲喜捨などなどやっておけば OK です
私も何人か日本の方々にそれを提案しちゃって
最近誰かの大阪の方でね
人がね 自分があのお母さんがね
まあ最後になってだったら私に言われたんだから
どうしようもなく 大きな文字で慈悲の瞑想ってもう貼ってあげて瞑想してくださいと頼んだんだと
それでお母さんも一生懸命やっていたみたいなんだと
やってみて ものすごい微笑みの顔で亡くなったんだと
そうなんです それで本人チェックしたら
お母さんが瞑想してなかったみたい
なんか祈ってたみたい
という疑問だったからね
私は教えたりしますよ
生きとし生けるものを教えたりしますよとか
それで私に聞いた質問が
それでよろしいんですよ
言葉どうでもいいでしょ
お母さんちゃんとやったんだからね
祈るって言ったって 瞑想って言ったって
そんなのどうでもいいんです
本人が真面目にやってやって天国に行ったんです
それでしょう 我々にできることは
孤独死するのは怖い これに答えましょうか
孤独で生まれたから孤独で死ぬんです
誰も一緒に死んでくれませんね
だから孤独死は嫌って思うのは何ですかね
みんな孤独で死にますよ
二人で一緒に死んだことがある？ないんです
死は孤独です 生まれることも孤独です
個人個人で別々に生まれるんです
双子で生まれても個人個人別々です
だからこれは人間の妄想の結果なんです
そういう質問が これで私に出された質問をそのまま流しちゃったんで
だから色をちょっと変えたんだけど
あまり色違い見えませんね
こっちは見えますけど
これは引用ですね 私の文章ではないんだから
しっかりした文章やと思います
年を取り 足腰の痛みが年々ひどくなってきて
日常の買い物も疲れます
伴侶とは死別し 子や親類と疎遠です
皆それぞれに大変に迷惑をかけたくないという思いがあります
耐えられる人はおりません
先日 ひどい風邪を引き
布団の中でふとそのままこのまま死んでしまったら寂しいな
いろんな人に迷惑をかけるなという
思いがよぎりました 孤独死を避けるにはどうすれば良いでしょうかね
孤独死を避けられませんね
私も時々思う 自分の部屋で一人でいて
で そのまま死んじゃったらどうなるのかと
で 協会の方も用事がなければ電話しないしね
たまたま電話してね 事務所の方で私は受け取らなかったら
どこかに出かけたと思っちゃうんです
死んでいるかもと思ってくれないんです
もし死んでいたならば
そのうち発見するでしょう
でもそれは私が人に迷惑をかけたことですかね
じゃないでしょ これは管理管轄外でしょ
私は一人でいる時でも
パッと発作を起こして死ぬかも
だから他の連中は家の中で死体があるのは嫌だったら勝手に処分すればいいでしょうに
別に私が迷惑をかけたわけじゃないんです
はい それに答え出します
ギリギリまで自分のことを自分で行うという気持ち
決意が必要です まず 孤独
孤独死が嫌だったら まずギリギリまで自分のことを自分でやってください
毎日 身の回りのことを整理整頓してください
それはできることです
なかなか私たちほど皆様にできないと思いますよ
私はもう 73 になりますけど
そろそろ いまだに自分のことを自分でやるんです
誰にやってくれない たまにやってくれる場合がありますけど
迷惑 だからおいおちゃっと生き方はね
まず 今日晩ご飯天ぷら食べてんだからねとかね
一言葉言うだけで あの調子やめたらどうですかね
ギリギリまで自分やるべきことをやる
天ぷら作らないんだったら
家の掃除とかね 買い物をしてあげたりとかね
自分が買い物をして 奥さんに天ぷらにしましょうよと頼めば
材料切るぐらいやってあげますよとかね
あげることはちょっと腕が必要ですからね
そういうことで いつでも我々はあれ
生活習慣にしましょう
自分に出る来ることは何でも自分でやるというね
偉そうに子供たちに言うくせに大人はやらない
毎日 それから毎日会う人々と付き合って知り合い友人にしてほしい
あの若者だけじゃないんですよ
知り合いを作らなくちゃいけないのは
いつでも知り合い作ってください
人々で付き合ってみてください
だいたい日本の田舎だったら
老人たちがみんなお互い仲良く付き合ってるでしょう
あれってすごいかっこいいんです
そこで老人の仲間でお互いに助けあげることはできませんだけど
一人が老人会に来なかったら
何々さんがどうなったんですかねとかね
喋るでしょ そうするとそれなりの責任者に連絡するでしょう
今日 老人会にお互い文句言い合ってる人ね
会いに来なかったんだから
何さんが ちょっと調べてくださいと
そういうことになります
それから医者 看護師とかね
毎日会う人がいるでしょ
人って そういう人といっても仲良くしてください
あ こんにちは 先生 元気？とかね
俺は元気じゃないんだけど
先生はどうとかね 先生は元気でいなかったら困りますよとかね
そういうふうに年上だから何でも言えるでしょ
医者に で バスに乗ったらね
バス運転手さんに 特に年寄りが一言葉挨拶すると
これすごい機嫌が直りますよ
バス運転手っていうのは自分の孫みたいな人でしょ
一言葉挨拶して褒めてあげたら
遠くに住んでいる子供に期待するより
村の老人たちと仲良くしましょう
これで孤独に孤独で死にたくないという問題は解決します
次 安楽死 社会と法律が認めるならば
自分に罪はない 自分の命を亡くすことではあまり罪はないんです
誰かが一人 医者ですね
自分を殺さなくていけないでしょ
安楽死の場合は それは問題です
例えばヨーロッパとかは安楽死を認めていますよ
法律的に だったら安楽死そんなものが悪くないんです
自分で自分の死を決める決めることだから
でもヨーロッパでも係の医者が注射するんです
命を助けるべき医者を殺しや殺しの専門家にしてはいけません
医者って殺しの専門家ですよ
本当に肉体に苦しみがないように
安楽で息を止める方法を知っているんです
だから 我々が知っている自殺と違って
医者っていうのはプロですよ
人殺しで何の苦労もなく
それでいいんですかね
それはいけません 理由は人の病気に真剣に当たることができなくなります
医者の仕事は殺すことじゃなくて生かすことなんです
だから人が病気になったら
我々仏教的には当たり前と思うんだけど
医者はそう思わない これはおかしい
これは変 治さなくちゃと思っちゃうんです
それは医者の仕事なんです
だから安楽死を認めることで
医者が信頼できない人間になるんです
あるんです それ 現実的に
例えば 3人ぐらい安楽死させた医者は
自分面倒見ている他の患者さんについてもね
あまり病気になったって言ってあまり気にしない
あまり気にしない これあまり良くないでしょ
業の決まりによって必ずただで
ただでっていうのが一番大事です
業の決まりによって必ずただで死ぬから
余計な感情を控えた方が良い
だから安楽死や何そうやと考えないでください
なぜならば 自分が苦しんで死ぬ業だったら
これは避けられません
しかし この世の中で一本先行しているならばね
ぽっくり死にます 死はただだからね
それにも金がかかってきた
だから私のポイントはこれなんです
安楽死そのものが悪行為でもないんです
例えば自殺そのものが罪じゃないんです
ただバカだけだったら死ねるんだからね
自殺するとお金かかるでしょ
だからそれは自殺性の場合はこの前半大丈夫ですよ
この激しい暗い感情で自殺するんですよ
明るい気持ち 自殺しませんでしょ
だから自殺する人々は 99.99%
すごい暗い感情でやりきれない感情で自殺するんです
ドカーンと落ちるんです
あれは怒りです あれ 自殺が罪だからじゃないんです
自殺した気持ちの結果です
だから ニータスには読んであるとわかる人は自殺はしないんです
その程度の理解があったら
自殺はしてはいけない
自殺罪だからじゃないんです
自殺を引き起こす衝動が危険です
そういうわけで安楽死も同じ
だからただでくれるものに
なんで金が払うんですかね
いらない だから 業が決めたように放っておいてください
唯一できる安楽死は断食です
私はあの私も尊敬する師んでいた亡くなったあの先生の教授の考えで受け取ったんです
仏教ではあまり推薦しませんよ
仏典ではないんです 断食してみてくださいと
仏典はいつでも業に任せたと
例えば阿羅漢たちは今日夜亡くなりますよと知ってるかも
知ってます 私の命は今日夜前半までやと宣言までやと知っていても昼ご飯食べます
日常生活は普通に行います
しかし あの先生はもうもう役に立たないんだから
命を止めようと思って断食を取ったんです
断食取ったら完璧でしょ
医者にも迷惑かけてないし
何もやってない だから安楽死だったら断食するしかないんです
死ぬまで しかし それが楽
楽ではないんです 2日3日までは結構厳しいんです
それから体の感覚はなくなりますから
あまり関係楽になります
最後には 2日  3日  2日までは断食
苦しいね 喉が渇いてとかね
苦しいんだけど それでも続ければもうどうでもいいってことになっちゃうんですね
はい  10番目の質問 余命宣告された人へ
論理的には本人に知らせるべきです
だいたい余命が医者に言われても家族に言うでしょ
患者さんに言わない 日本では告知しないというのが普通ですね
アメリカでヨーロッパではドカーンと本人に言う
何のことはない アメリカでヨーロッパでも全然問題を受けてない
みんなすごい明るくそれに対応する
嘘を言う文化ですから
こちらでは告知しない
告知しないということはかっこよくない
嘘をつくことだから だから中間を取ってね
まず論理的な立場は本人に知らせるべきです
だって仏教は子供の頃から死常々瞑想しなさいと言っているんだから
命は儚い 死は確実やと念じなさいと言っていることだからね
だから仏教の答えは告知しなさいなんです
本人に 死をすることは智慧のきっかけになります
智慧が現れます 生まれたもの皆
死の告知を受けているが
私は死ぬわけではありませんという態度で生きている
生まれた瞬間で告知を受けてますよ
お前死ぬんだからね 我々も告知受けてます
でも態度 俺は死なないという
本人の人生観を見て 告知するか否かを決めてください
本人が欲があって 執着があまりもあって
家に執着するわ もう預金帳に執着しているわ
あれやこれやもうハチャメチャだったら言わない方がいいんです
だから告知するかしないか
この患者さん 自分の親戚だからね
親だからね おじいさん
おばあさんだからね で
よく知ってるでしょ 人生観は
その方々の その方々に育てられたんだからね
だから自分の母親のことを告知される先生に
自分に母親どんなものかと自分が知ってるでしょ
だからそこをチェックして
これは言った方がいい
言わない方がいいと決めてください
本人に仏教の教えなどを参考にして
死という絶対的な現象について教える
あの あなた 3ヶ月寿命やと言うんじゃなくて
ただ説教する まあ歓喜する間でなんとか言う
まあ何やっても人って死ぬもんだなとかね
何でも無常ですねとかね
体は毎日衰えていくわ
若返ることは一切ないわ
まあそんなもんだな 世の中はとかね
そうやって観察的に説教するんです
例えば看病するお母さんにリンゴを切って食べてくださいって言ったら
お母さんが 1個食べただけで残っていて
まあすごく食べごろでね
美味しかったんだ リンゴが悪くなっちゃったねとかね
ほんの 1時間  2時間置いただけで
じゃあこれはもう死んじゃったことです
捨てなくちゃいかんとかね
そういう風になんとなく喋ると
本人の命に関係ないことに気をつけてください
リンゴも無常で死ぬんだとかね
そこで何か死っていうのは何か大人前のことになってくると
なんとなく告知できるようになります
告知できなくても 本人が人は誰でも死ぬんだからね
うるさいこと言うなよと怒られたらやめてください
もう本人知ってるんですからね
はい これで休憩取ります
はい 次のタイトルは 生きることは死ぬことですと
これは仏教的な普通のことなんですね
常に死んでいくから常に生きている
だから生きるっていうことは
何か壊れて何か現れる
それは生きることなんです
だから仏教では死と生っていうのは一緒にするんですね
世間で言っていることとは違うんです
次の命の価値っていうことにいきましょうか
命に価値があるのかと
価値は花瓶の花にありますか？花瓶にありますか？花瓶に花入れて価値があるでしょ
どちらにある？まあ答えないかもしれませんが
しおれた花を捨てて花瓶を置いておくでしょ
結局は 無常だから価値がないんです
これで理解してください
無常たるものには価値がないんです
だから花瓶の例を出したんです
ちゃんと花を生けて 花瓶が花を生けておくと
どちらに価値があるのかと言っちゃうと
難しいね 答えるのは 花瓶が花をハイライトしているし
花が花瓶をハイライトしているし
一緒の境なんですね でも花が枯れたら捨てます
結局花瓶が残ります だから花は無常で
花瓶が無常ではなかったんですね
一時的に そういうわけで一切は無常だから価値がないんです
生きる命とは 生きるとは
命とは無常の流れです
無価値の流れです 生きることにも価値を見出せないならば
死という瞬間の出来事を大げさに受け取る必要はありません
別に気にする必要はないです
今も価値がないしね 価値がなくて変化している
だけ まあそれも変化していくんです
瞬間の命 生まれた瞬間から細胞が死んでいったのです
今も細胞が死んで新たな細胞が生まれていく
この死がなければ命もありません
細胞が死ななかったら生きられませんよ
化石になっちゃいます
命は 命とは心の機能が物体に起こることです
ある物体に心が働いている
ある物体の中です だから肉体は事務所で事務所に勤めている人は心ですね
人が出ていったら 事務所はただの建物です
心という機能は光速度よりも速く消失していく
物質はゆっくり変化しますけど
心は光の速度よりも十何倍速くサーッと消えていくんです
だから命は瞬間 心がある瞬間で命がある
次の瞬間で死んじゃって
次の瞬間で新たな人間なんです
肉体物体の 復活できないところが皆思う悩むしです
みんな死と言っているのは本当の死じゃないんです
肉体が機能停止しただけの話なんです
心のことじゃないんですね
心はもっと早く死んで生まれて
死んで生まれて 死んで生まれて流れているんです
また問いが入りました
避けたい 避けたい死に方
怖いのは嫌だ 不安なのは嫌だ
後悔したくない ボケたくはない
痛いのは嫌だ 悲しませるのは嫌だとかね
まあ答えはもう言っちゃったんだからね
避けたい死に方 怖い不安は今の感情です
今死ぬはずがないんだから
もう将来 将来妄想して不安になるだけですね
だからこれは大したことはないね
死ぬ時どうなるかわからないんです
その時にならない限りわからない
だから不安は無駄です
怖いということも無駄です
本当はその時になったら怖くないんです
後悔したくないなら 今から後悔しない生き方をしなさい
ボケについては説明しましたね
悲しませるのは嫌だ 死んだあなたを他人が悲しんでいるか喜んでいるかわからないので
余計な悩みです 思ってるでしょ
もうみんな私が死んでから悲しむの嫌だとか
いい加減にしてください
あの連中を喜んでいるか
よくよく見ると高価な弁当食って喜んでいるんじゃないんですかね
余計なこと 命を正当化するための言い訳に過ぎない
そんなのは死にたくないという気持ちがあって
自分の命を正当化しようと思っているんですね
ただの言い訳ですよ このうわごと以外なんともない
あの質問11は 真剣に悩むなら
それなりに何とかします
例えば 死ぬのは怖い 不安だ
周りを悲しませたくないということを真剣に思っているならば
いろいろ手を打つんです
手を打つんです だから
それは問題ない ただ思っただけでね
妄想でしょ 俺は金持ちになりたいなと思ってみてください
歌ってみて なれるかどうか
真剣じゃないでしょ だから質問 11 はやっぱり真剣だったらあまり問題ない
何とかします 次 見事な死に方
じゃあ副題は言わなくてもいいでしょ
見事な生き方が見事な死に方になる
だから生きることは死でしょ
だったら見事な生き方をしましょう
それだけ仏教はそれを教えてるんです
今も死んでると思えば
私はいない 存在しないと思えば今も幸福
死も幸福です ただ 試しに私がいないと思ってみてください
すごく楽しくなります
そうすると生きてますよ
いないんだけど 私はいないんだけど
生きてはいる 私ではないんです
現象が 色受想 色受想行色がね
肉体と心が活動している私がいませんと思ったら楽です
そうすると死ぬのも楽です
人格向上 心清らかにすること
煩悩 感情を乗り越えること
智慧の開発 こう漢字間違い
真理っていうのは漢字間違い
その心理じゃないんです
真実の真理ですね 真理の発見
他の人のね 役に立つ生き方
慈しみで溢れる心 これらを生きる目的にします
これはメモってください
真理の漢字だけ誠にしてね
心ではなくて これを目的にしてください
生きる目的 だって生きることに価値がないでしょ
価値がないんだったら目的を作りましょう
いわゆる無理やりに価値を作る
私は知恵を開発しなくちゃとか
そこで価値が現れる 私は真理
この心理学の心理じゃなくて
真 誠の真理ですね 真理を発見しなくちゃ
人の役に立たなくちゃと思ったら
もう価値があるんです
あるいは慈悲を実践しなくちゃ
そこを覚えて生きてみましょう
価値が現れます 見事な生き方です
それは微笑んで死を迎えます
見事な生き方が見事な死に方です
皆にではさようなら お世話になりましたよと臨終の時言えます
ではさようなら お世話になりました
と言って死にます 持参できるものとできないもの
えーと あの世に財産 家族
地位 名誉 権力などは持参できません
でもそればっかりです
上がっているのは それだけ目指す人は虚しいんです
手ぶらで貧乏で 仮だけの身を背負っていくんです
だからそういう人は 死ぬ時は手ぶら
貧乏 たくさん負を背負っています
だってお世話になってなってなって
そればっかしでしょ 借りたくさん
その死に方 不幸ですよ
だって持参できるものばっかり探していたんだから
道徳の経験 積んだ徳 調教した心の能力
行った功徳が持参できるんです
大富豪としてあの世に行く
いいでしょう あの世に大富豪で来たければ
で 道徳を守る 徳を積む
善行為をする 心を育てるということをやってください
それは持参できます ゴミばかり収集する人生をやめて
精神向上という宝物を収集する生き方に変えましょう
それだけ私に言いたいのは
とにかく飛ばします 次に心に要注意
心を甘く見てはいけません
すべては心次第 心はくせ者
心はワンパターンでループで回転したいんです
ワンパターンでループで
汚れた思考妄想のパターンができたら
改良は難しい だって皆様知ってるでしょ？いつでも同じことばっかり考えてるでしょ
これ心の癖なんですよ
体力能力が低下している臨終の時には変えられませんよ
今まで考えた同じ妄想を繰り返しちゃうんです
これ危険です 汚れてない思考
慈しみの思考のループを作れば
死は安全です だから早くも今から汚れてない思考をやってください
癖になってください 慈悲の思考を癖にしてください
そうすると体が壊れちゃって寝たきりになっても
慈悲だけ回転するんです
ループは それは幸福な死に方になります
瞑想実践に慣れている人は死は
死は怖がらない ヴィパッサナー瞑想を実践していて
結構経験がある人の場合は
悟りに達しなくても 死にかけてくると瞑想が勝手に入り込むんです
心に ヴィパッサナーが勝手に入り込んで瞑想させちゃうんです
だってやること何もないんだから
観察するだけ 考える能力もないんだから
思考妄想もないんです
だから本当に純粋にヴィパッサナーができるんです
だから もしかするとヴィパッサナーをすごくやっている人が死ぬ瞬間に悟るかもしれませんよ
我々わからない もう死んじゃったんだからね
それで 結論としては 各者の死は究極の幸福です
解脱を目指しましょう
だから幸福な死に方というのは悟ることなんです
それが幸福なんです 他の死に方は大したことないんです
はい これで今日のお話は終了です
ありがとうございます
時間的には ありがとうございます
[拍手]やっとセーフです
ごめんなさい では 最後の
はい そういうことで この最後の物事を終了するとき
我々の瞑想があります
それは祈願と書いていますけど
それをやってみんな一緒に唱えましょう
全部出します ドゥッカパッタチェニン
ドゥンカ バヤンパッタチェニンバヤ
ソウカッパッタチェニスソウカ
ホントゥサンヴェーティパーニノー
もう一回 ドゥッカパッタチェニン
ドゥンカー バヤンパッタチェニンバヤ
ソウカンパッタチェニスソウカー
ホントゥサンヴェーティパーニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
どうもありがとうございます
それでは 本日の注目を終了とさせていただきます
ありがとうございました